l'avis de camionneurs c'est loin d'être
facile
les journées sont longues les trajets
peuvent durer des semaines
et bien s'alimenter c'est tout un défi
la montrant ce qu'on mange aux la
cochonnerie mano l'italien et qu'elle
use depuis quatre ans on m'a enchanté à
notre demande
manon lance un appel aux 28 mille
membres du groupe camionneurs
camionneuse du québec 2.1
je m'attache qui monte des bouffes santé
quand ma mère mais c'est sûr qu'on mange
son appel porte fruit les photos
partagées montrent une tendance
on compte beaucoup moins deux repas au
resto qu'on leur ait imaginé comment
adapter sa coach en poussines allemande
et je penserai pas de 200 pièces par sa
mère n'a mangé les restaurants
on est sur les routiers atteignent voir
ça mange pas camions d'armes camionneuse
qu'est ce que vous mangez robuste le sac
which à quoi les gens manquent
avec ta matin
quand les gens
c'est gênant ça la petite patate
écologie du ballon au nez des batailles
c'est vous qui l'avez fait or ces mamies
mais dans mon corps d'un gros déboires
ça vous arrive de manger
à l'aller
thomas
ça coûte trop cher et puis tu sais pas
marcher pour l'amiante
quant au moins atteindre c'est un peu
plus facile comme ça vient
c'est vraiment quelque chose de pas trop
lourd
les lanières de poulet doit un peu
grunge précis ce populeux c'était quand
même saint-hubert quand même possible
les etats unis se soient mcdonald's dans
lequel c'est plus un autre mais tout
s'est produit à faire le folliste on
peut aller par attend un camion ah oui
on allait finir votre frigo saint andré
le monde se démarque par la qualité de
son alimentation
le chauffeur de 53 ans a préparé tous
ses repas pour la semaine d ici est dieu
qui est chaumont avec des failles
pénurie ma bouffe d'un camion c'est moi
qui a préparé à maison dimanche
je fais toutes mes plongeons amputé
diplôme à montréjeau d'âge des petits
objets des légumes se sont gonflés
millau le monde mange mélanger des
camions si je le vois le plus bel
exemple c'est lui michel bar salon
[Musique]
le camionneur le plus fort bien
au total un peu plus c'est un emploi qui
demande beaucoup qui demandent de
l'attention il faut est éveillé et ses
deux longues heures de conduite c'est un
entre 11 et 13 heures de conduite par
jour sans oublier les chargements et les
déchargements je n'ai pensé à vous
ça me
sur la route à nourriture j'ai tout
alors on arrive à l'alto routière
j'avais quand même une tendance plus à
arrêter dans les grosses chaînes mais
j'ai réalisé que souvent c'est moi qui
paient la note
en bout de ligne côté santé lorsqu'après
quelques dates
tu vois tes cheveux qui sont enflés pas
c'était quand même assis tout le temps
contrairement à maintenant je me nourris
mieux je fais un peu plus d'exercices
marché m'arrêter tout cela combiné
enfants qui font que ça rend mon métier
mon travail de tous les jours plus
agréable et plus facile ledit matins à 7
ans des lacs michel cuisine sert pas
pour la semaine avec sa conjointe qui
n'ont trop-plein jacky barbecue haricots
ça qu'on construit selon mon repos ne
revient peut-être à 8 dollars
économiquement sur budget et santé je
regagne 1 à tous les nouveaux fruits et
légumes noix protéines végétales
michel c'est le nouveau guide
alimentaire canadien sur deux pattes ou
sur dire où je me nourris à 80%
végétarien donc dans ma semaine je vais
avoir un rapport sinon aux 2 où il ya
une portion de viande aux dépenses je
dois admettre que j'étais un peu
réticent parce que un bon steak tu
j'aime ça j'ai vu mes journées être plus
facile à brooklyn
affaire am nourrissant végétarien ben
merci bonne semaine le dîner sa voix de
mon repos le plus consistant
un peu plus tard dans l'après midi je
vais prendre une pause et là je vais me
préparer une assiette soit de noix avec
quartiers de pommes oranges et ou des
crudités avec une trempette cachette
cegid chocolat malgré quelques écarts de
conduite
les camionneurs demeurent préoccupés par
leur état de santé
enfin pour galan d'activité fait congo
ces douze enceintes et moi j'ai perdu
mon père à côte la santé nous en pensée
l'état camionneurs lui tout face à 45
quand vous avez une frais égal qu'est ce
que vous mangez sur la route
le dépistage pour l'instant et puis
quand même 68,2 m ça va dans les
dépanneurs des haltes routières plus
facile de trouver chip ses chocolats que
fruits et légumes
il est dit au vu des bananes suis dit
vous devez déprime ce matin à pau au
québec on est pas vraiment choyés en
fait halte routière là moi je pense
qu'il pourrait y avoir des kiosques
salade d'avec poulet ou encore le de
certaines grandes chaînes
l'ofs mais c'est une petite portion
je suis sûr que à court et moyen terme
il y aurait un succès avant de prendre
sa retraite michel donne de la formation
ou jeune camionneur
il en profite pour leur parler
d'alimentation j'ai formé quelques
chauffeurs et qui peut arriver avec la
mentalité du chauffeur d'un camion qui
manque du fast-food tout le temps et
lorsqu'il voyait les reports j'avais
souvent avant même la formation d'un
mois qu'ils étaient avec moi déjà dans
la dernière semaine qui arrive avec un
plat cuisiné de la maison dans un pot de
vin
donc je me disais on a franchi une étape
donc si la personne part de jeu pour moi
0 au port maison à ne serait-ce que
quatre repas maison
il va y prend goût mais aussi est
tranquillement changer sa chanson
alimentaire
[Musique]